yes happy Thursday
[Laughter]
everybody okay all right they use their
might to spy on the right a new report
from the house Judiciary Committee
reveals that under the guise of
investigating Jan 6 the feds asked Banks
to do a search of transactions for
indicators of homegrown violent
extremists problem is according to
Congressman Jim Jordan the treasury
Department asked the banks to conduct
the search using terms like Trump and
Maga in an effort to track gun purchases
they also ask the banks to query terms
like query terms like yeah I don't know
like Bass Pro Shops and Dicks Sporting
Goods so in other words if you so much
as bought a jock strap at
Dicks then you could have ended up on a
federal Target list list of domestic
violent
extremists that explains luckily I knit
my
own takes two balls of
yarn but domestic violent extremists
that's quite a mouthful right why don't
we just shorten it to what the feds
really mean Republicans now of course
they're using Jan 6 to justify all of
this they use it to justify everything
they're trying to cram more under that
umbrella than Chris Christie at a nude
beach seriously I don't think anyone's
gotten more out of a single date than
since Megan went home with
Harry little British
humor true Jan 6 has been milked more
than the Octo
mom there's a call back but in this case
the excuses are as weak as Joe's urine
stream according to Fox digital
treasury's excuse is that the searches
were actually begun under the previous
administration H hey guys I think I
think you're already in a hole two more
shovels full and Joe and Hunter will be
able to talk to their Chinese Partners
face to face cuz if that's true if in
fact treasury was using Search terms
like Trump and Maga while Trump was
still in office then they were
investigating the supporters of the
sitting US president you know like John
KY after Botox that's not an
improvement now our president heads the
executive branch treasury's under that
Branch so really they were conducting an
investigation into their own boss I mean
that's like cat investigating me and no
I wasn't licking the sweat off your hair
extensions it gets worse according to
Jordan Bank of America also gave the FBI
a list of folks who made credit card
transactions in the DC area between Jan
5th and Jan 7th 2021 and customers who
had made any historical purchase of a
firearm or had purchased a hotel Airbnb
or airline travel within a given date
range
note to self always use cash when
participating in an
Insurrection and sleep on Shannon
bream's
couch reportedly Bank of America did all
this without asking for a warrant and
they're still called Bank of America
more like stank of America am I right I
came up with that one now luckily I
don't use that bank I have this Nigerian
prince who handles all my money his
name's Charles Payne
meanwhile BFA is doing warrantless
searches on behalf of the feds on Search
terms that are so broad they are by
definition going to turn up more
Innocents than Targets this is supposed
to be a valid use of the nation's
investigative resources just months
after our Ci's practically burned to the
ground during the 2020 Summer of
Brotherly Love if only they wore red
hats we'd be calling that a Civil War in
response to these allegations of helping
the FBI BFA claims they were acting on
instructions for from treasury now is it
me or is this entire Affair starting to
sound as circular as a fruit loop old
school Lawman called this
self-supporting investigation a
self-licking ice cream cone which is
also the secret service code name for
Joe
Biden but another term for it could be
unethical or perhaps even illegal it
would be like if Trump asked Planned
Parenthood for all the records on women
who had abortions or people who bought
electric cars or people with IQs under
cuz in fact when FBI supervisor Steve
Jensen saw this info he reportedly
ordered it purged from FBI systems
because the leads lacked allegations of
Federal Criminal conduct that might be
the understatement of the year right
behind the view induces
vomiting so let's ask the FBI a question
you guys were investigating anyone who
had a previous gun purchase and who
traveled to DC before the inauguration
so did the name Hunter ever come up
now I should clarify I mean the name
Hunter and not the noun hunter or else
you'd happily arrest this guy
instead yeah that's Donald Trump Jr on
the right so according to Fox digital
the FBI has declined comment which is
fed speak for let's get past November
5th to see if we have to retire but I
don't think no comment is going to cut
it this time this feels like one of
those things that you know like anal
warts and Joy Reed they just don't go
away
H I said show a picture of Joy Reed in
the
meantime
terrible in the
meantime there are lessons here for
those of us who might disagree with the
administration if you so much as buy a
whiffle ball bat at Dicks pay cash if
you eat at Crackle Barrel wear a
disguise if you ever stood for the
national anthem watch your back and for
God sake make sure your tax returns are
perfect or maybe it's time to start
living your life under the radar assume
an identity that's safe registered
Democrat declare yourself non-binary
send a donation or two to plan
Parenthood or just change your name to
Biden hell you won't even have to pay
taxes but you will have to pay 10% to
Daddy Let's tonight yes he's the only
guy who looks and smells like cashew and
his now you know tour starts in February
comedian Jim
Norton he always reminds us why the
founding fathers were right host of
Piers Morgan uncensored on Fox Nation
Piers
Morgan and she's been eating well since
most birds flew South New York Times
best selling author and Fox new
contributor cat
tip
and he trims his beard with a flock of
sheep New York Times bestselling author
comedian and former NWA world
champion Jim has a noted legal scholar
must find these Revelations about the
doj using these Search terms utterly
disturbing do you worry about the feds
looking at your Search terms in your
private transactions
um no because I always just put what I'm
doing on the actual venmo like I'll say
bag of coke for the White House hooker
things like that yes so what are they
going to do get me you know that's what
you should do just put ridiculous things
you mentioned anal warts I mean who
hasn't had a few cases of those yes I
order them off Amazon oh yes don't laugh
they're
delicious is this crazy is this what
happens when you brand half the
population it's I mean I'm starting
tonight trust the government um and I
don't like to feel that way but yeah
it's disgusting and it's disgusting and
whoever that FBI agent was that actually
got rid of that that supervisor uh he
did the right thing but it's not
surprising it's just it's disgusting
yeah you know uh Piers uh we usually see
this kind of complete overstep and abuse
of power in your
country Well it Well we had an a great
example of this I wish I could come here
like a normally do and take the super
cilious high moral ground uh but we had
a case involving Nigel farage you might
be familiar with him a big conservative
figure in the UK and he was banking with
the queen Bankers by Royal appointment
Coots Bankers in the UK and suddenly his
account got deleted gone and he asked
why wasn't told eventually the reasons
why leaked out it turned out it wasn't
for the reasons that they said which was
he hadn't hit a certain credit level and
so on it was purely because he was Nigel
farage a conservative with conservative
views therefore he was obviously a
racist blah blah blah blah blah and he
won that case and the boss of the bank
actually had to resign in a huge Scandal
so it's not just a problem here it's a
problem everywhere and the the Common
Thread is Banks know everything about
all of us if you think about everything
that you do on a daily basis pretty much
all of it funnels through your bank so
if the fed's here and banks in England
are behaving in the way that they are
it's a pretty shocking invasion of our
lives and probably way more than we
realize yeah that's why I keep my money
in one of tyrus's
socks $80
million hey Cat all right you can gloat
gloat all you want I was going to gloat
so this is what happens when you assume
the government can be trusted in the
area of surveillance so the Glenn
greenwalls and the Julian assange's of
the world were right all along sooner or
later it was going to come back to the
American citizen of course so I'm not
surprised by this because there's no
Fourth Amendment when it comes to
financial records the federal government
basically did away with that decades ago
with a very predictable justification of
abuse and of foreign bank accounts right
they always say there's this evil
foreign other they need to protect you
from and really they use that power
against you um law enforcement doesn't
really need a warrant to access your
financial records uh look you can look
up the bank secrecy act you can look up
um third party Doctrine basically the
justification is you can't expect
privacy because you've given that
information to a third party meaning the
bank like try going through life without
having a bank account right but that's
why I'm a Libertarian that's that's why
I can't vote for either major party
because they don't take the Fourth
Amendment seriously you can't just say
okay you know what but we're only using
it for this and then get upset when it's
done to your side you should be get
upset when it's done to anyone and
they're always going to use it for
political reasons they're always going
to do that so you just can't give them
that power in the first place when they
start saying you know security safety
those kinds of things that's when you
need to think okay what what are they
trying to make me afraid of and what do
they gain if they win cuz of often this
is what is really going on
I well thank you for the pre-app lause I
never trusted Banks after The Beverly
Hillbillies that Mr
Dale awful man Mr Dale uh Tyrus what do
you think of my advice about just
changing your identity becoming a
liberal so people just stop tracking you
doesn't work well in terms of Parenthood
doesn't work they still find
you maybe maybe you shouldn't do a
national popular TV
show what like like there's so many
Tyrus it's a very common name um we're
forgetting one thing I hate the grouping
the government the government no no no
the problem with the government is that
people run it and dirty people who
decide that they're saviors and martyrs
and that they know more than the
taxpayers do that's the problem in
America because your story was great
because somebody did something wrong to
a conservative and then what did they do
they went to this thing called court and
there was law and then the bad person
lost his job and probably was
financially responsible we haven't got
there yet in America we're just at the
part where we just Rob the conservative
blind and say well what what are we
going to and that's it here's the thing
you don't need to have FBI to check out
what mag is buying because we all pretty
much buy the the same thing M bunch of
water ammunition for rifles bug shot
bird
shot Diet Coke for those who are
trying so true and camouflage hats and a
ton of American flags not hard to find
out and I that's it I love Bass Pro
Shop I will go into Bass Pro Shop just
to look at the alligators yeah like I'm
just in there having a good time it's a
great if you've never been to a Bass Pro
Shop and they're not marketing although
I I will take endorsements but it is a
great place you don't feel like taking
the kids on an adventure bring them to
the bass pro shop and let them go around
and see all the stuff it's a great time
but again this it goes back to you CAD
is so right but again we need to stop
saying government and start calling
these people out by their name because
that's the only way you stop it bad
people hide behind FBI say the name of
the son of a who's doing this
because then we know where he is all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else